everybody welcome welcome welcome
welcome
to the December New York open
statistical programming Meetup hope
everyone's having a good time as we
start to wind down the year some of you
may have already started winding down
the air three months ago some of you
haven't yet but hopefully you guys as
the calendar year is coaching and I hope
everyone's having a nice time and is
excited for another talk
that's good to see everybody hope
everyone's having a wonderful uh
Thursday I believe it is hope everyone's
enjoying their time so first up
as we always like to do we always like
to start this Meetup by asking who is
hiring now I know it's kind of hard to
say who's hiring and here in fact it's
impossible if I want to go up and say it
except for myself or our speakers or
Nicole so if you are hiring and you like
to hire someone from this community go
to the NY hack our slack it's my
hackr.slack.com we have a link to it at
myheckcar.org and go to the job postings
Channel and post your job there you'll
see we recently had a few postings I
think two in this past week we've got in
many people's jobs both back when we
were always in person and now that we're
virtual through this slack channel so I
hope we get more and more people jobs
it's always nice to do that
I myself am hiring looking for many
positions that aren't even on our
careers website because someone has to
update it and that's me
um but we're looking for a data
scientists shiny devs looking for people
like Linux admin experience looking for
account Executives and sales people uh
so lots of positions at
landeranalytics.com or message me
because you know you could all find me
on my hack our slack or Twitter or
LinkedIn or wherever
uh so again if you want to post a job go
to job postings at the my hack our Slack
as we always do we have pizza so this
month's pizza came from Rocco's Pizza
Joint I'll get a nice close-in shot of
that you can see this is a grandma slice
it was baked in a pan that's why it has
the charm in the bottom a little um
inverse bubbles I wouldn't test the
cheese lock on this because it's so
heavy from all the crushed tomatoes that
it's not going to stay up there but it's
a really good place like under the radar
place it's like looks like a corner
slice joint and if you walk past you
might not notice how how great it is
particularly for their Grandma slices as
I have here
so if anyone else has gotten pizza or
any lesser food from any other type of
Cuisine let me know jump in the chat let
me know where you got your food from or
your beverages whatever you're eating or
drinking or not eating or drinking let
us know in the chat hopefully you got
some pizza
um we all know that's my uh my favorite
absolute favorite food borderline on
Obsession but I hope you all enjoy
whatever you're eating
next month January we would be both in
person and virtual I want to say thank
you to brainstation for hosting us in
their beautiful space down in SoHo where
we will have epec and sorry talking
about how to analyze complex patient
generated mobile Health Data so it's
gonna be really cool as a topic and
it'll be really nice to be both in
person and virtual the announcement will
go out probably sometime next week and
we'll provide all the information again
if you want to attend from anywhere in
the world it will be on streamed on our
YouTube channel and you could actually
chat and comment right in there or you
can chat and comment on our slack
Channel
and I'll also be in person like I said
in SoHo so we look forward to kicking
off the new year with this in-person
Meetup
for tonight or any other night I guess
um when you have questions you can put
it in the zoom chat right here or even
better you could put it in the slack
Channel we have a channel called monthly
Meetup chat if you put it in there it's
a lot easier for me to collate the
questions and ask them of our speaker
afterwards because I can't copy and
paste from Zoom for some reason I don't
know why but it's killing me but I can
from slack so join the slack community
and ask your questions in there please
uh also some people have asked we held
our our gov conference uh two weeks ago
now it seems like yeah two weeks ago
um so the videos will be up in the next
couple weeks um we're editing the videos
right now actually Nicole is doing it
all uh so it takes a lot of time to edit
these videos hopefully get them up
within the next two weeks for everyone
to see like you see I am wearing the
T-shirt because these are conference
t-shirts make up like 80 of my wardrobe
at this point I have multiple colors
from multiple years on multiple
conferences so it's great
so with all those announcements I would
like to welcome and thank our speaker
fresh from speaking at argov two weeks
ago
um we had a hole in our schedule and we
asked her can you speak like in two
weeks and she's like sure so we're very
very grateful and very excited to have
Dania come speak to us everyone please
welcome golf club for Dania
the talk title is you are an analytics
engineer
um if you are at the rgov conference you
saw me and my colleague and dear friend
Max Richmond give a very similar talk um
I actually stole half the size for that
talk and I'm spending on it here today
but in a nutshell this is a story
about me a data scientist and my journey
of discovering that I need analytics
engineering
so strap in I think this will be a fun
ride
um so starting off uh hi my name is
Dania
um Dania morale to be exact and I
thought I would start off with a picture
of just like some things about me some
words people used to describe me
um I have been I was pretty active in
the Our Ladies DC I'm based in DC well
I'm based in the suburbs of DC now um
usually pretty active in the Our Ladies
um in DC when the pandemic happened I
moved out to the suburbs so I haven't
been active since like early 2020 I'm
sad about it and I really want to get
back in but I will forever be an Our
Lady
um some other just job titles that I've
held in the past have been statistician
quantitative analysts
um I dabbled in customer analytics
management for a year and decided that
that management maybe isn't the thing
for me but
um good experience jump back in into
being a senior data scientist that's
what I do now
um but on the side I'm also a dance
teacher I'm a fellow a dance teacher you
can see this picture of me with my kids
um and I love doing that and I feel like
it's a pretty important facet of my
personality
um oh I even skipped over this my claim
to fame is I met Hadley in grad school
um if you know Hadley and never met him
he's really cool uh his Instagram is
also very fascinating he puts a lot of
baked goods on there which is not all
related but cool guy he's a hero and I
was really happy that I got to meet him
um yeah anyway also a dog Mom this is my
dog uh wife uh and I also have a yeller
about Dei issues and Tech uh if you know
me professionally you know I spend a lot
of my time at work like talking about
this uh on the internet elsewhere if you
want to talk about diversity Equity
inclusion belonging any of that stuff um
in Tech uh come talk to me I love
talking about that but none of that is
super important what's more important is
um I think I might be able to get the
title of analytics engineer I don't know
if I'm quite there yet but I have spent
this year kind of I don't know
discovering that maybe I am um and it
looks engineer now so let me tell you
that story
so before I start there I want to talk
about what is analytics engineering it's
a pretty it's a pretty new term
um like we all love our our buzzwords
and I feel like this is one of the big
buzzwords I've seen in like 2021 2022
um so analytics engineering is really
like the intersection of data analytics
and data engineering so data analytics
as most people are probably super
familiar with it's
um when you're using data to make sense
of a business of
of something
um identify patterns develop
recommendations like you're making sense
of data when you're working as a data
analyst data engineering is more on the
setting up the database maintaining the
database optimizing your database and
your data for
um Speed and Performance and it's sort
of very focused on the data not so much
on the analysis of the data
now what analytics engineering does is
it translates that that information from
the database to being more analyst
readable so it incorporates
um business information it optimizes the
analysts abilities like really quickly
make sense of the data so that you can
use it to apply to your business or
whatever your application is
um and you do that while also optimizing
for Speed and Performance so you kind of
get the best of both worlds you get like
all the good stuff from data engineering
and then also all of the other analysis
information that you need
um like I said analyst engineering is
not something that I really realized was
a thing that existed it was always like
oh I gotta clean data like I don't want
clean data
um but learning to embrace that that
step of uh the full like data science
life cycle has just completely changed
my life
but like how did I get here it's like
how did I really realize that I needed
analytics engineering so this past year
um this is this is a little bit of the
story uh so the exist this tech company
I work at it it's called Arcadia
um and our uh goal is to decarbonize the
grid by giving access to community solar
to all people
um quick aside so what is community
solar um you think of solar you're
probably thinking a rooftop solar where
you put a solar panel on your roof the
issue with rooftop solar is well one you
need you need a roof you need to own
your roof too
um
super expensive
um your roof has to be facing the right
direction there can be trees in the way
it's like there's a lot of barriers to
entry
um and you don't want to have barriers
to getting access to clean energy so a
community solar does is instead of
putting it the onus on the individual to
put solar panels on their home you group
these panels together on in these solar
Farms um and it can be on an actual like
legit Farm it could be on a whole bunch
of roofs together but basically you have
developers that build these solar farms
and then anybody that lives in the
community surrounding
um that that set of solar panels can get
the uh electricity that comes off of
um that farm and then you now have
access to clean power without any of the
various entry
um and we hope that Arcadia what we do
is we try and get as many people on as
possible to increase the demand
um so then give developers a reason to
increase the supply of community solar
and then really make a difference in um
the the state of the grid anyway moving
past that so basically I work at this
company
um and we have our business goal was we
want to try and get every single person
on this platform and we want them to be
um a customer for as long as possible we
want to maximize our lifetime and so the
marketing team was like how can we
identify
individuals who will maximize their time
with us and if those individuals are not
going to maximize their time with us
because of reasons what are those
reasons and how can we change our
product
um to make it more accessible so I
walked in and I was like oh data science
is this sounds like a Predictive
Analytics problem this actually sounds
like a survival analysis problem
I was like let's do this let's build a
model and so I told the marketing team
that I and my team could build a tool
that would predict the likelihood of a
customer staying given that they convert
based off a bunch of features about that
individual so demographic features
geographic features psychographic
features any all that stuff
and so really excited and I was like we
can build this in R this is going to be
awesome and I quickly discovered
that this was not quite as easy as I
wanted and had to do with the data so
the first thing is I needed to be able
to capture
um more of this I need to be able to
capture this feature data and it didn't
exist in any of our core databases I
need to go to external sources to get
this data and once I got that data I
needed to be able to store it somewhere
along with all of my existing customer
data and the reason I needed to combine
those two things was I wanted to know
what the survival looks like for
existing customers and then also know
what their demographic psychographic all
those other
um
points of data are
um I also discovered I need to update
this data periodically
um and I have to have some way of doing
that like every time I get a new
customer or a new lead
um I need to be able to know what is
their survival
um looking like and who these people are
and the other big thing was I needed to
be able to standardize the business
definition of like who even is a
customer and I needed that to save
somewhere in the database and what I
mean by that is it's
are you a customer if you
um went onto our website and like signed
up are you a customer if you are already
put onto a project what if there's a
projects available in your area are you
a customer then are you not like this is
a business decision that needs to be
made and once that business decision is
made it needs to be saved somewhere that
where everyone is kind of um accessing
the same definition
um
once I built the model so that's all
like pre-processing stuff once I built
the bottle I needed a place to store
um my derived predicted values and
relate them back to my larger data
ecosystem so like basically put it into
um
production
um and then I need to be able to export
this to
um my marketing team in a way where they
could work with it which is like ah okay
how am I going to do that and also make
sure that they get the latest version of
the data
um and then finally I needed to be able
to document everything I did enforce
quality
um
and like maintain the entire system and
I was like ah how am I gonna do all
these things I do not have any of these
things figured out what I realized that
I was saying was I was missing the
elements of a good data foundation so a
good data Foundation has many steps and
there's the first half of just like
getting the data through the door that's
like your generation your storage your
orchestration your transformation
um pieces and then there's also the
actual like analysis of the data and
like delivering it or exporting it out
to people
who need to like gain those insights and
use those insights um and then there's
also governance and Discovery and like
documentation
so if you group those into two things
you end up having like two sections of
your data Foundation there's a concept
of having good data and there's all the
pieces involved with that and then
there's a concept of using data well
and all the pieces associated with that
and so the question for me became how do
I do this like how do I build this type
of system that has both of these
um core pieces of of my data
so to figure that out I had to take a
step back and think a bigger picture I
need to think about like the data
architecture Evolution and this is what
like this is when things really started
opening up for me and I really started
to kind of
going into this field of analytics
engineering
so quick background
um have you ever heard the term ETL or
extract transform load that is generally
how you get data into a data warehouse
so a data warehouse is a highly
structured
um place where any of the data that
exists in like your application
databases it you extract that
information you transform it into the
structure that you need in your
warehouse and then you load it into your
warehouse and then from there if you
want to make any
um
business decisions or understand your
data you do that like in your report or
in your analysis like you do that within
the SQL query or within the um our code
that you're doing
now the issue with this is that it's
very limiting because you have to make
sure that everything is structured um in
the exact same way and that doesn't
always work with different types of data
now a data Lake it's another big
buzzword I think of 2020 2021 2022
um that takes that flips ETL and makes
it elt so instead of extracting
transforming the data and then loading
it into your Warehouse you instead
extract your data load it into your data
Lake and then when you need to you
transform it and the reason that's
really useful is now you can have like
various types of data all stored in the
same place all stored within your data
like and you know how access to a bunch
of things
um the thing that became really useful
for me in this case is if you go back to
the beginning when I was saying I needed
to get a whole bunch of like demographic
and psychographic data none of that
stuff like existed in any of our like
core data bases for a company and so I
can now use third-party software to um
pull in that information and then just
like upload that into the data Lake and
save it
um other ways that we've used this is if
you ever have like Google Sheets or
Excel sheets just like data saved in
csvs you can just ingest that directly
into your uh data Lake and go go forth
and use that which is super super
powerful
and then from there with all this
information that exists again within
your report and within your analysis you
can do the
um the adding of any sort of business
definitions that you might need
but I don't quite want to do that either
I want that business context to be part
of my system
um and so that's for the concept of a
lake house comes in so lake house is
what we call the um like the canonical
sense of source of truth that contains
all the business logic and all the
complexity
um and so and that allows you to like
build things off of that business
complexity without having to like really
think about it so is that in another way
um the the concept of who is a customer
that can be defined within your lake
house
um and have that definition can be
derived from like the data that exists
within your data Lake and when you go to
count how many customers there are you
can just pull directly from the concept
in the lake house instead of having to
Define that in your query every single
time you try to count customers and so
you end up having like very stable data
um in the stable counts down the road
so how do you do this
and who does it those are the two next
questions
um so like I said before the analysts
you're doing the analysis of the data
and Reporting things back so it looks
kind of the analytics space the data
engineer that's a person that's
maintaining your data Lake
um maintaining sort of all of those uh
El process extract and load processes
um and optimizing that for storage
timing all those things but your
analytics engineer that is a person that
takes all of that stuff in your data
Lake and takes all of that information
they know about the business and builds
your lake house
which is not I don't know if that's a
term that we use across the board that's
a term that our KD uses for this
um and so you end up with
this lake house that has all these
canonical terms
um and it is agnostic to all of the
input systems it's just all of the data
transformed in the way that you need it
um so that you can now pull it for your
reporting the tool that you use to do
that transformation and that maintenance
is DBT
so this is actually this is a really
long-winded way so I'm about to give you
a talk about DBT
um if you've never heard of DBT before
this is something that uh is pretty it's
a pretty new technology I actually just
heard about it a year ago and I I don't
know this entirely I think it stands for
data build tool I don't know if it's
true or not uh check me about later but
basically this is a company that's built
this tool that allows you to build these
lake houses
um and these analytic engineering layers
so now I'm going to do you know your
BuzzFeed headline version of what DVT is
so five things to know about DBT which
is a transformation workflow the first
thing is it's implemented in Python
um and in a nutshell it basically takes
the power of python and takes the power
of SQL and just sort of like matches it
together and makes you do SQL book
better
um one of the ways that it does this is
it uses Ginger templing
um which allows you to use Python
functions and
um write queries in a templated form
using this gender template form and then
turn that into executable SQL like I
won't say that I fully understand all of
the ins and outs of how that works
that's very much more the data
engineering side of it but the thing
that Ginger templing allows you to do is
it allows you to handle dependency
management and that from me as an
analyst is huge
so what I mean by that is
if you've ever been in the situation
where you will wrote a query
um and it's based off of some source of
data and something changed in that data
source but you're not aware of that it
failed silently
um and then you wrote that query you
find out that this this doesn't output
the way I expected anymore and I expect
something changed but you were not aware
of that what DBT allows you to do is
candle that dependency management and
make sure that things fail loudly
so in the example that I have right here
if something changed you can see that
this final customers table is dependent
on a staging customers table which is
dependent on the raw data coming out of
the data Lake if something changed in
that raw data in the data Lake
um DBT would tell me hey something has
changed in your data and it will
probably throw you an error and when I
go to look at my customers table I know
um that something has changed so like it
really helps you maintain the data
integrity and if something has changed
um Upstream
and make sure to run that thing upstream
and then let everything that is
Downstream of it
um kind of fall into place so you
manage all of the different dependencies
for all these things and this dependency
graph this is a very simple one it can
get extremely complicated once you start
like really building a daily chaos
um
the other big thing is uh it allows for
macros and configurable tests using a
EML file so that's just like another
markdown I think the unlock stands for
yet another markdown file but basically
you can add markdown to your SQL with a
bunch of information about what is in
your query so this is like uh this is
commenting on steroids but the the big
piece here is that you can create tests
on your queries where if the tests fail
um
you know right away like there's
something wrong with your query or
there's something wrong with the
underlying data go check this
um so yeah it really really helps you
understand what is happening in um your
queries and it also uh helps you know
like maintain the Integrity of your data
and all of your reports Downstream
um and I will go into this because I'm
going to be showing you um a big example
for all this but the last piece is it
also gives you these really great um it
gives you great great documentation out
of the box
um this is like a small snapshot of it I
will actually walk you through
um a piece of documentation
that we have with the example that I'll
show
so before I start talking about DBT
um by itself I also want to talk about
dimensional modeling uh shout out to
Ralph Kimball
um if you have worked in databases or in
SQL this should be something that's like
somewhat familiar but it's not totally
okay this is actually something that I
also only really learned the last couple
of years
but dimensional dimensional modeling is
a structure for how you manage your
tables within a database and the lake
house which is where the transformation
is happening of your data from a data
Lake the power of the lake house really
comes with how you structure your data
so if you follow a certain format for
that
um you can get some really powerful
insights out of your data very quickly
and that you can do three-dimensional
modeling
so in the demand in dimensional modeling
there's a bunch of different types of
tables that
um have different definitions of how
they should look and those are these
tables here and I'll talk about those in
a second but before that
um in DBT I want to talk about how you
get from data in your data Lake into
your lake house so backing up a bit data
in your data Lake it's unstructured
and it can come from multiple different
sources so what you want to do and what
DBT
um suggests that you do is you build a
staging table first which is basically a
as is
um copy of the data in your source file
and what this allows you to do to do is
it reduces the number of reads that you
have to make
um from your Source system
um which is like super computational
expensive it makes things kind of speed
up and once you have have this data in
your staging table now you can really
um
transform it into whatever way you want
and so when you transform it depending
on what data is inside of
um your staging table you can Define
what type of table you want to create so
if we want to create a dimension table
that would be a very very wide table
with a whole bunch of attributes about
an entity so if you're thinking about
customers it'd be like everything that
you want to know about a customer you
would have a customer each each unique
row would be a customer and then you
have this massive wide table so anytime
you have that type of data you want to
create a dimension table anytime you
have information where it is measurement
of an event so like transactions for
example those are facts so you want to
create a fact table and you want to end
up with a really really long table that
has all of your measurements of an event
um some other ones that are um slightly
more complicated as our Bridge table
that's those are tables where you have
many attributes
um of one entity and many attributes of
another entity and you want to combine
those together that's called a bridge
table and so if I'm ever looking at
um a table and it has like BR or Bridge
um in front of it I will know oh this is
a bridge table this is comparing a many
many to any relationship between two
entities which is where this becomes
useful
the last one I'll talk about is a slowly
changing Dimension so this is like a
very wide and a very long table this is
basically a dimension table but with
historical records about entity
um scds are really really powerful we
actually most of the lake house that um
Arcadia uses we have it's just full of
scds
um
but they're kind of complicated uh but
the the point of all this being defining
what type of table you are creating
right before you do that transformation
the data is really powerful and it
really helps people Downstream
understand what type of data they're
looking at
so let's go through an example let's go
through an example of um
building a system with DBT and at this
point I don't know if you're fully
convinced with why this is this is
useful it really just seems like okay do
some SQL um but in like a slightly
different way and that's true but I hope
by the end of this example it like I can
really show the power
um
so here are two really simple raw uh
pieces of data two tables that exists in
a database database it's called EB
public
um there's just like an internal
database that we have at Arcadia and all
it has is zip code information so the
ZIP Code table
has an ID for every zip code it has a
state ID
um and then it has a city the states
table that has an ID a state ID
um a name an abbreviation associated
with the name this is a super simple
example
um but I think it still shows the the
point
so the thing the issue with the zip
codes table in its raw form is it only
has state ID and I want to be able to
know as an analyst I want to know what
state the state ID is State id47 doesn't
actually mean anything to me I want to
know what state that is
so you're probably thinking like okay
that seems like a really simple query
you just like select all from zip code
you join in the state ID to ID and then
you'll have
um all the states associated with your
ZIP codes which is correct that is
exactly what we're going to do but we're
going to do it like in a slightly more
fancy way
so the desired output is we want a
dimension table as I explained before
because for every entity we want all of
the information about it
um and we want to know we want an entity
table for or sorry we want a dimension
table for zip codes
but we want the dimension table for zip
codes to be dependent on your your
um raw zip codes table loaded into your
lake house as a staging table and then
fold into your final transform table of
a dimension table but you also want the
state information so you also need to
take your raw State information pull it
into your lake house as a staging table
and then turn that into a dimension
table that you can then use and combine
with your ZIP codes to create your ZIP
code dimension those are desired output
so how do we do this
well first we want to create a staging
table
um for States so like I said before the
point of a staging table is you want
that data that is in that like kind of
unstructured place
um in the in the data lights to be
pulled into the lake house as an exact
copy and then we can transform that data
so pulling that in as a copy
um the state table we are just defining
it exactly as it is and it is just a SQL
query where I'm saying the ID from this
table I want to call it state ID I
called EP state ID in this case because
the raw data is called EP so just like
know what that raw source is
um the name I'm going to redefine it as
a state name so it's like super clear to
the analyst
um abbreviation they're called state
abbreviation superclues to analyst and
then I am missing from
a slightly different thing so this is
where the ginger templating is and
source is a function that is in Python
that DBT uses to pull from The Source EP
public that's the database and the table
States
um and what so right here this is like
almost equal it's not fully SQL when you
run this it becomes compiled SQL and it
actually builds this staging table
so to run this you just run the code you
just run the command in your console DVT
run
select and the name of your table
and then what DBT does is it compiles
and builds this table and tells you look
it this this work this met all of our
um basic expectations for a query
completed successfully and then if you
go to query this table you'll see it's
like I created or go to SQL query I
create a table fantastic
super simple
so the next piece is okay so I created
the staging table and now I want to take
that staging table and I wanted to
actually make it a dimension
um this example is kind of silly because
I don't do anything with it I don't do
anything different from the staging
um state to the
um the dimension state it just I now
have a dimension table called States uh
it looks exactly like my staging table
I'm referencing
um the stating table to build this I run
my SQL query or sorry I run my DB team
does it work correctly yes it does it
was completed successfully and now I can
query my DM States
so why is that interesting and I was
like no that wasn't super exciting
um but what you can do now in dbts you
can add a yaml file to that query so
this is what a yamla file looks like
just using markdown
um and this is saying that for my model
it's named DM States this model uh it is
it gives you information about states in
the US and it has three columns so you
have your EP state ID your state name
and your state abbreviation
and for each column it gives you a
description
um and then within each of these columns
there is a test so the test that I want
to ensure for this table is that every
state ID is not null that's null is not
an option and that it is unique
same with the state name I want to make
sure that's not null and it's Unique and
same with the abbreviation
um I don't want any dupes and I want
them
to not be null and if anything enters
this table that is a is a duplicate like
if there's two marylands for example
um this test will fail and DBT will be
will tell me when I run DBT test it'll
tell me hey look there's there's
something wrong this test failed um
there's something wrong with uh the
state of your table
so that's that's super powerful and this
is like a little bit of a silly example
that you can imagine for like really
large tables why that might become uh
very useful
DBT does have a lot of tests out of the
box uh if you go I I literally copy and
pasted this from the DVT docs
um it has four tests out of the box it
has unique uh not null accepted values
which I think is super interesting and
relationships and these are just tests
that you can pull in directly
and put in any of your yaml files and it
will apply to your model
um you also have the option to customize
tests and make your own tests and then
save them as a macro and then pull them
into vml files to apply to any of the
models or the tables that you build
um the accepted values test is one I use
a lot it tells you these are the only
values that are allowed to show up for
the status field in this particular
example and if any other
value shows up DBT will fly to you hey
something has changed your data go check
it out so that's super useful
going back to our example
um again so our desired output we want
to get this DM zip codes table right so
we've built we pulled in
um our State raw data we create our
staging table we create our Dimension
table and now we're there now we need to
pull in the basic zip code information
make it a staging table and then finally
combine these two to create our ZIP code
Dimension table
so again this is what the data looks
like this is what the raw zip code
data looks like
so again I'm going to write my staging
table
um where I take the ID I name it
something super clear the ZIP code ID
the relationship
um it's going to be the same name as
uh the state
and the values I do a little bit of
cleaning to make sure that my ZIP codes
make sense
um and I also give the all the fields
types another thing that we do
um at Arcadia and I will probably carry
forever is whenever I write SQL we make
sure that we order our fields in a
certain way so we always put all of our
identities first all of our fields that
our relationships to other
um tables that goes next all of the
fields that are values we combine those
together and then at the bottom
um anything that's like a time stamp we
usually
um group those together as well and so
the nice thing is anyone else on your
team can go look at your queries and be
like know exactly what they're looking
at like what type of field that is and
where it exists so it's just like a
smaller side
um
again it is pulling from The Source EP
public it's pulling from the table zip
codes I run
um my DBT run command to see to build
this table and yes I completed
successfully uh I can query this now I
now have a staging table
and now I want to turn this into a
dimension table I uh have my ZIP code
um table I'm pulling in from the
stagings of codes but this is slightly
more interesting now because I actually
want to pull in the state information so
I'm doing this join here where I join
the states
um with the state IDs onto the ZIP code
stable and I save it I do DBT run again
I see does this work yes it works great
I've created this table now I want to
make sure that this table exists and it
has all of the
um
Fields all the fields maintain their
integrity and so I can build a test
um and I do that within my yellow file
so in this case same thing created my
ammo file with all my descriptions
um defined all my tests and then I did
DBT run but in this case I
um DBT fails I've done something wrong
oh no
um if I was braver I would do a live
demo but it was not so we're going with
great shots
um so if you can see here it was it
failed on the unique
um test in DM zip codes for EP state ID
and the reason it failed it tells you
down here it says it got 51 results this
test got 51 results but it was
configured to fail if it was equal
greater than equal to zero and so if I
go look over here I see ah yes on the
zip codes table
I don't want to have uniqueness as a
constraint because there will be
multiple state
the multiple duplicates of States
because there's obviously multiples of
codes in one state so I'm like oh I
don't want this test here I just put
this in here so you can see this is what
it looks like when it fails so if I take
all that stuff out run it again it's
like oh look it's fine I don't actually
want that I'm there but had this been a
situation where I did have that
uniqueness constrained and something had
changed about my data and it was no
longer unique you would get an error
just like this and that's an example of
how that shows up
yeah so we've done it we've used DBT we
now have this table
um and it tells us for our ZIP code what
is the name of the state and now what it
exists in our lake house if any other
analyst ever wants to know what the
state associated with a zip code is it
can just pull from this DM zip codes
table they will never have to like
actually write the SQL again because it
just like exists as a table
um and the really nice part here is the
final output the documentation that's
associated with it
so this is what the DBT docs look like
this is the steams of code stable is
actually a table that we have
um at Arcadia and here it shows you the
documentation tells you exactly what the
description is and this is pulling
directly from the yaml file it tells you
what columns there are what the
description of the columns
um are what the types are what it's
referenced by what tests it uses what
models depend on it in this case the
term models in DVT
um means tables which can be a little
confusing if you're a predictive modeler
um but yeah and then it'll actually show
you the source um SQL and then the
compiled SQL which is great so ever
since we adopted this lake house
um world and we started using DBT uh our
ability to build
um and expand our team has just
gotten so much faster
um because anything that anybody else
builds it just like shows up in our uh
DBT docs and so you can just go look up
any
um information you want
um about our lake house and you can see
here we have so many of them
foreign
how am I doing on time
I think okay
um so
the all of this talk I title this talk
you are a manoliths engineer and I did
that on purpose because this does sort
of come back to arm
um so going back to the original problem
statement I told my marketing team that
I could build a tool that would predict
the likelihood of a customer staying
given that they convert based off of a
bunch of features so I wanted to take so
basically I'm building the machine uh
learning workflow and I want to take the
machine learning workflow and I want to
take all of the things I've learned
about DVT and I want to put them
together
so you can get all of the optimizations
um and the data integrity and the
documentation from DBT and apply it to
your about workflow so in this case the
um
the model is taking in a bunch of demo
psychographic geodata I'm taking into
rival data past and current customers
and combining them together I'm using
the RMS survival survive minor packages
in R to do some survival analysis I
modeled then outputs the probability of
survival at a selected time period
so 30 days 90 days what what have you
um and so then I will be able to tell
you this customer with these
demographics like a graphic geographic
features
um is whatever percent likely to stay a
customer at 30 days based off of
um past customers with similar
um information
now
you can really unlock the power of your
ml workflow if you apply the DBT
structure to it so in structuring your
data the first piece of information that
you want is your observations model so
you want to have a dimension table that
is in your Lighthouse that contains
exactly one record per every observation
that you want to make a prediction on
so it would look something like this so
I have two customers this is all the
information
from there you create you do all the
modeling R and then the output is your
predictions model and so this is going
to be a fact table where it collects
facts or every new prediction you have
about any um
observation sorry every record
um every new prediction you have for
every customer
um it will show up as an observation in
this model so for example uh for
prediction for customer one the first
prediction on ten one is one year for
customer one again the second prediction
that you have on ten two is 1.5 years
and then customer two and so it's just
like a very long table of facts
and then the final table that you have
the production model or in this case
table uh is also a fact table where you
get one record per observation for the
latest prediction joined in and then all
the downstream exports and reports and
everything point back to this model to
this table
um and therefore whenever you're giving
your stakeholder any information and any
um exports you build off of that it's
always based off of the latest version
of your model
so another way to visualize this is it's
in your lake house you have your
observations model
getting your analysis in an R you throw
it back into your predictions model and
again model and DBT means table uh and
then you store that into your production
model and everything exports from there
and just like I showed you before all of
that great stuff all that documentation
and all of those tests and everything
um can be applied to all of these uh
different tables so that you maintain
the most
um data Integrity that you want
so that's a lot I hope you learned
something I hope you understand what DBT
means now
um this is all stuff that I learned in
like calendar year 2022
um and really the way that I learned it
is just through a community of practice
and the community practice for me just
happened to be my job itself
um
and the entire data analytics team at
Arcadia this year basically became
analytics Engineers we all discovered
this is something that we really need to
do we need to get all of our data in the
data Lake and into the lake house so we
can have all of our business definitions
um and so it really has been kind of a
team sport
um and it has been incredibly incredibly
helpful to have data Engineers just like
by your side for every step of the way
because the stuff is super complicated
um so yeah through all that I I sort of
learned how to be an analytics engineer
um a couple of shout outs got a shout
out Max Richmond uh he gave the the
condensed version of this talk with me
at the uh our gov conference uh
conference two weeks ago Sam Swift
it's actually a New York native
um he is our VP of data systems and he's
actually the guy that brought all of
this knowledge to Arcadia like has
really taught me so much of this so if
you know him he's great uh if you don't
know him like he's a good good person to
know uh knee uh was a teammate on my
team who
actually did all of that survival
analysis that I was talking about so
gotta shout her out and of course thank
you to uh Arcadia State Engineering team
and the analytics team and of course
thank you Landry and looks and Jared for
welcoming me back to speak yet again
and I am ready for your questions thank
you
thank you so much and we're a pleasure
to have you speak always you've spoken a
couple of our conferences our Meetup now
and we'll hopefully have you again yeah
I would love to speak again
uh I do see a few people just saying
thank you it was great it's a little
golf clap uh hurdanya
um so a few questions we'll go through
uh so first of all we did confirm the
EBT stands for data build tool aha great
Amada who used to work for us uh you saw
for the Meetup she works for DBT now so
she's really excited to answer that yeah
thank you Ramada
um so there's a bunch of questions so
first we said it's built in Python but
it seems like it's all SQL so you don't
do you need to write python code to
write this so it's all SQL I think I
think if you're the data engineer
implementing it you need to do some of
the Python um as the analysts or the
analytics engineer uh not so much it's
really just like writing that sequel
um structured way
so how is a data Lake there's a two-part
question it has a data Lake that's
different from like a very extensive
data warehouse and how's a lake house
different than views in a database
because if you pre-computes things for
you yeah
um that is a great question that a data
engineer would be more suited to answer
than myself uh I might I might Pond
um
I think there are probably many
different ways of being able to do that
and I think views are one one big way of
that I think the the big piece with the
lake house is being able to use the
um
the tools the additional tools that DBT
gives you and implementing that within
your Lighthouse I think that's what that
true power lies that you don't
necessarily get with views the visual
tool you said
like the visualization plus like the
documentation plus the the yaml files
and the tests and like all of that stuff
if you implement all of that within your
lake house uh that I think is unlocks
additional power
okay so it's all like the nice tools
that go around it yeah
okay
um then the lake house is it duplicating
since you say you make copies like
staging copies of the stuff in the in
the lake is that just duplicating the
data so now you have like duplicate or
triple kit copies of your data set
kind of yeah yeah so it and the reason
for that is again it's more of a data
engineering thing it has something to do
with maintaining like you don't want to
touch you don't want to keep pinging the
the data Lake for the information
um every time you try and transform it
because that will be very computational
expensive so yeah you do want to keep a
copy of it
um somewhere
there's also there's another specific
reason that has to do with the ginger
templating and how um its DBT is able to
do the
um the dependency management which is
why that staging table is really
important but I don't know if I could
speak to like the full full reason why
all right so it sounds like we are
making multiple copies of data which
sort of goes back to um the old way of
doing things where analysts just got a
read-only copy of the database
um so the data the lake house isn't
itself a database or is it a file system
like what is it built on postgres or
something uh for us yeah it's building
snowflake yep it is it is a database
um
and it's core
but the difference is it's come it's the
difference between a database a data
Lake and the lake house is the lake
house is a database of structured data
that comes from your data Lake which is
a whole bunch of unstructured data from
a whole bunch of different
data sources and structures so data lake
is a database of databases
lake house is a database that pulls them
up data warehouse was back in the day
the database a databases
you kind of do it yeah and I think a lot
of the stuff is also very buzzwordy
right now like I'm sure there are other
terms for it that have existed for much
much longer and these are just the ones
people use now
a lot of what I'm getting from not from
your topic in general about the modern
data stack is just SQL with variables
yeah that's exactly yeah it's like stuff
we were doing 20 years ago we just
calling it completely different things
and it's easier to use them yeah so
reading like Ralph Kimball's book and I
was like this is like this came out in
the 80s like you guys have been thinking
about this for so it's just now learning
about it and it's just hot now
it's like I've been trying to follow the
you know since probably your talk from
the conference and now a lot of it seems
like you know reinvent not reventing
just taking what was made in the 90s and
making it easier yeah
um and there's a question are you using
DBT core or DBT cloud
um
okay so then that brings up the
follow-up question
are you aware the pricing changes they
made today and the new restrictions they
made so full disclosure I discovered
that right at the beginning of this this
meeting uh yeah kind of sucks but I
guess that's good for them because uh
clearly their product is is useful and
people are willing to pay yep
um okay so then
um so the yaml test okay this is gonna
be one of those more questions is this
different than like constraints in a
database table
yeah um so sort of like it is it's
essentially what that is I think I think
the the yaml test the ability to build
these like custom macros uh that test
unique things that you or I don't say
unique but test uh things very specific
to your data I think that's where like
that real power is so the stuff the
custom stuff that comes out of the box
that's that's great
um but what we have really gotten the
power from is being able to build these
custom tests that is very specific to
our data okay yeah but then the past if
let's say one row fails on a test does
the whole thing fail or can you still
use all the other rows that didn't fail
this has been a big issue so as we've
implemented DVT and we've like learned
this
um we've had to learn about we've had to
kind of restructure it to like being a
hard fail to warnings because yeah there
are there have been times where
something something super Upstream will
fail and everything like the whole thing
shuts down it's like oh it won't fail
and so
this is the give and take right on the
one hand it's like I know exactly I know
my data is like perfect to a T at any
given moment but also it like it might
not be working at any given moment
because everything is always failing
um so having a good team of data
Engineers to monitor that
um we have an actual person with the
title of analytics engineer and her job
is to really monitor
um that and maintain that that is a
pretty big piece of it
um but yeah there are ways to
um set it up so it doesn't completely
shut down your entire system and just
aware that okay you might not have a
hundred percent quality
and speaking of being aware like do you
get alerted by email or slack or carry
your picture you have uh we have a slack
integration um we have just like the I
think it's like feed lake house is the
slack Channel and every time there's a
run every hour tells you did it fail to
succeed if it failed these are the tests
that failed this is the model this is
the actual like query that failed and
then you can go fix it
is there like a health dashboard telling
you how the system is going we we have I
don't know if there's one out of the box
from DBT but what we have done is we've
built one that we have in half
um that we use internally so you're
really deep in the modern days deck I
know hex is another big one I know you
want me to come back and talk about
hacks that's that's my next stop that's
I think you would like that now I know
another speaker from the conference
Sarah
um she was one of the investors in HEX I
know she's really super excited about it
and she's super excited about DVT so
yeah I really want them to build out
their like our bit in the heck so like
it's still uh in beta but oh man the
power that's gonna unlock I had a
conversation with the hex people back in
2020 where they're when they're actually
looking to be invested in we're looking
for investors and they show me
everything in Python that's really cool
can we do something in our
um so hopefully hopefully they'll come
around to that so
yeah it's a really nice product yeah
um okay so you're ready to do your
analysis your survival modeling getting
the data out of DPT just sounds like you
use DBI treat it like any other database
and just do a select or something like
that yep well actually before I actually
do this question the data
um since to me it feels like a view is
it more of a materialized view like when
you query from R to get the data from
the database is it running calculations
right then or is everything pre-computed
as a materialized view
I think it is the latter okay
I think it's saved that way that's a
good question
I don't this is why I see this is when I
was a manager of the team and not
actually doing that so like we need me
in the room to tell you the answer
okay because I know like it's like I
know with views I know these to me it
feels like views that's what I'm asking
with a regular view every time you say
select all from view it has to compute
the view of materialized view it's
already computed and stored yeah yeah
and so and it's it's much faster when
you do it this way which makes me think
that it is a ladder but someone should
check me on that
so you got your data out of DVT into our
creating like just like a regular
database at this point yeah yeah
you fit your fancy survival model right
so then how do you
use that model like a new row of date a
new customer comes in you want to score
them how do you use that model in this
whole process yeah so
um the so the output so this is kind of
the power of R compared with like with
the power DVT like being all the output
are
um
the predicted values like I'll put you
can even output that as a CSV and then
like load it into your Lake and you know
put it into a lake house like as soon as
that happens as soon as you get more
information then like you need your R uh
you need the the model to run again so
that that was also the other thing that
we needed to do was like create
um the word is escaping me right now the
Brisco create a schedule for every time
we get new data
I think once again it runs periodically
it updates the values it goes back into
your like your prediction output model
that goes into your production model and
then that model gets pulled in let's
break that down so a how do you call the
r the r model to score every so often
like is it a cut Cron job or is that a
DVT yeah yeah yes you generated you have
five new records or whatever it is that
R scored how to get that back into your
DVT models or the way we were doing is
we were outputting that as um a CSV and
then it was just getting like
ingested back into the league all right
um and then I have some things I think
I'm Edgar um he's one of our he spoke at
myr this year
um he wrote a package called tidy
predict I think this tidy predict does
which translates some R models maybe not
survival models probably but some are
models into
SQL code
all right so my question's gonna be is
there a way to incorporate that into DVD
I'm sure there is I'm sure there's like
a even better way if like if I could
skip the step where I turn it into a CSV
and just ingest it right back into the
lake and then right back into the lake
house like that would be huge I haven't
quite figured that part out yet how do
you predict check it out as part of the
Tidy models team so
I'll write that down
cool hey glad I can contribute yeah
that's the point of this Meetup right
always anymore
okay so I think I went through all the
questions we got from the Meetup and
from this on the slack and from the zoom
let me just check if there's any last
questions folks now is your last chance
to sneak one in before the closing wire
um and let me know if you have any
questions we'll give I will install for
a few moments to see if people have
questions
um and if nothing comes in I will I'll
make some announcements sorry
um
I'll just recap the announcements that
we made earlier while we see there's any
last tables
yeah any last questions I mean all right
so folks jobs post them in the job
postings channel of my hack r
uh Pizza I hope you all eat some good
food
the January Meetup is January 24th with
epec and sorry talking about analyzing
patient generated mobile Health Data and
the um our gov videos will be up in the
next two weeks or so so hopefully see
everyone both virtually or in person in
um January at the next Meetup
so with that let's give well that that's
the thing is everything
um I had a great time running about DBT
I had personally had a lot of questions
and wondering what DBT does so I got a
lot of clarity out of this so I want to
personally thank you for releasing them
for educating me
then I want to say thank you on behalf
of the little Meetup I hope everyone had
a great time learning I hope everyone
watching this on YouTube later has a
great opportunity to learn from you and
I uh thank you very much thank you for
everyone making this happen Golf Club
everybody for our wonderful speaker
thanks so much Jared
okay so you have a wonderful evening
thank you for being here with us
especially everyone also she did this on
such short notice like two weeks ago we
asked her like she came off the stage at
argov and said can you give another talk
and she said yes and it was really
really awesome that she did this
everyone thank you for the short notice
um and if anyone wants to give a talk
either in person or virtual send me a
message send Nicole a message tweet at
us find us on slack find us on LinkedIn
email us do whatever you need to do to
get on track of us and touch with us
because we would love to have more
speakers lined up in advance sometimes
we're finding people two weeks out
sometimes we're finding people six
months out so you know it's nice when we
have six months out makes things a
little less stressful
um so everyone have a great night thank
you for attending and see everyone soon
bye everybody